ein forschungsteam hat in mittel
australien jetzt ein gigantisch großes
vulkangebiet aufgespürt mit
siebeneinhalb 1000 quadratkilometern ist
es doppelt so groß wie mallorca
und nicht nur das die rund 8 100 neu
entdeckten vulkane haben sich auf
äußerst merkwürdige art und weise
entwickelt die erkenntnisse könnten
unser wissen über die entstehung von
vulkanen revolutionieren kick substanzen
fitschen jetzt täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal
activity glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
australien hat wirklich eine feurige
vergangenheit die so genannte kalkar
regie wurde kam provinz im westen war
vielleicht sogar am ersten großen
massensterben der erdgeschichte
beteiligt erst vor kurzer zeit hat den
forschungsteams dann im südosten von
australien die längste kontinentale
vulkankette der erde entdeckt jetzt gibt
es eine weitere super spannende
entdeckung in diesem zusammenhang ein
geologie team hat jetzt nämlich im
untergrund vom mittel australien mehr
als 100 alte vulkane aufgespürt und
diese sind wirklich nicht ohne
dazu heißt es in der aktuellen studie
diese vulkanische provinz erstreckt sich
über rund 7500 quadratkilometer
vergleichbar also mit der größe von
tirol oder eben der doppelten fläche von
mallorca
die vulkane aus dem jura zeitalter vor
160 bis 180 millionen jahren
entwickelten sich anders als es sonst
bei den meisten vulkanen der fall ist
stadt an den rändern einer erdplatte
nämlich entwickelten sich die neu
aufgespürten vulkane in der mitte einer
erdplatte eine absolute überraschung
auch für die fachleute selbst dazu sei
man holford der an der studie beteiligt
war während die mehrheit des irdischen
vulkanismus an den grenzen der
tektonischen platten unter den ozean
stattfindet liegt diese uralte vulkan
welt des jura tief im inneren des
australischen kontinents wir
interpretieren die boni vulkan provinz
als produkt der dehnung und das
innerhalb der platte stattfindenden
konfekt even auf strömen von gestein
über der sub dotierten pazifischen
platte heißes magma hat sich also von
der pazifischen platte die tief unter
dem kontinent gedrückt war durch die
darüber
liegende kontinentalplatte gebrannt so
konnten die neu entdeckten vulkane also
entstehen schon seit langer zeit stoßen
fachleute am sogenannten cooper eromanga
becken immer mal wieder auf rätselhafte
funde diese senke hält vor allem erdöl
und erdgasvorkommen bereit die schon
seit anfang der 60er jahre für die
wirtschaft von interesse sind der gar
nicht im untergrund dieser senke bietet
hervorragende bedingungen für ein
geothermieprojekt das hier getestet wird
doch nicht nur das nicht nur granit und
sedimentgestein wurden hier immer mal
wieder zu tage gefördert sondern auch
basalt dabei handelt es sich um gestein
vulkanischen ursprungs zum teil wohl aus
der trias und zum anderen aus dem jura
doch warum sollte es in der mitte der
australischen kontinentalplatte
vulkanische aktivität geben
bislang war das eine kaum denkbare
vorstellung für die fachleute
schließlich bilden sie vulkane dem
bisherigen wissensstand nach er an den
rändern einer erdplatte
das australische forschungsteam hat
jetzt alle vorhandenen daten zu dieser
region analysiert dazu der beteiligten
wissenschaftler
johnson hat man es gibt enorme mengen an
daten aus dem untergrund dieser region
aber das alter und die natur dieser
basaltgestein waren größtenteils
unbekannt aber auch seismische messungen
machten die spektakuläre entdeckung des
riesigen vulkanen gebietes möglich somit
steht jetzt fest in dieser region gab es
in vergangenen zeiten heftige
vulkanische aktivität davon zeugen nicht
nur die 100 vulkane sondern auch
ausgedehnte lavaströme und weitere
vulkanischen ablagerungen das
forschungsteam vermuten zudem auch das
ist hier einst kaiser und heiße quellen
gab dafür sprechen bestimmte geologische
strukturen die jetzt entdeckt werden
konnten die analyse der fachleute ergab
dass die vulkane wohl im zeitalter des
jura aktiv waren also zuletzt bei 160
bis 180 millionen jahren von diesem
vulkanen geht also keine gefahr mehr aus
anders sieht das bei dem vulkan
goldscheuer udine im osten russlands aus
droht mega vulkanausbruch mit
katastrophalen folgen anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren falls das noch nicht getan
haben sollte bis dann bleibt dran